mes chers collègues notre commission
d'enquête sur la pénurie de médicaments
et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française poursuit
aujourd'hui ces travaux par l'audition
de Madame Pauline londex et de Monsieur
Jérôme Martin co-fondateur de
l'Observatoire de la transparence dans
la politique du médicament
ancienne vice-présidente Paris vous avez
fondé l'ECS Metz en 2019 suite à
l'adoption par l'Assemblée nationale de
la santé d'une
Assemblée mondiale excusez-moi de la
santé je me disais celle-là je la
connais pas l'Assemblée mondiale de la
santé d'une résolution visant à
améliorer la transparence des marchés
des médicaments
s'inquiétant des prises élevés de
certains produits sanitaires et
constatant que les informations
publiquesment disponibles notamment sur
les prix variant d'un pays à l'autre
l'Assemblée mondiale de la santé invité
les États membres à renforcer la
transparence dans ce domaine en
encourageant la diffusion d'informations
sur les prix les coûts les coûts des
essais cliniques les unités vendues les
frais de commercialisation ou les
subventions reçues
convaincu de l'intérêt de ces
informations pour guider de façon
rationnelle et politique publique en
santé vous avez publié en septembre 2019
une check-list de la transparence sur
les médicaments
réunissant l'ensemble des informations
devant selon vous être rendu accessible
après vérification par des agents
publics
en octobre 2021 vous avez enfin publié
un rapport relative à la relocalisation
de l'industrie pharmaceutique en Europe
commandée par le groupe de la Gauche au
Parlement européen vous y défendez
notamment que la relocalisation de la
production des principes actifs
constitués un enjeu fondamental et
souligner les risques associés à une
concentration de la production dans les
pays asiatiques
vous y formulez également 10 propose 10
propositions relatives à la production
pharmaceutique invitant par exemple les
pays membres de l'Union européenne a
établir une cartographie des sites de
production publique et privées et à
mettre en place de façon coordonnée une
production publique de médicaments
sans préjugés des conclusions de notre
commission d'enquête il est clair que la
transparence avec la gouvernance
constitue un des mots clés les plus
fréquemment employés lors de nos
auditions encore faut-il préciser de
quelle mesure on parle concrètement et
préciser comment elle serait compatible
avec les règles encadrant le secret des
affaires comme les normes sociales et
environnementales prévalent en Europe
nous attendons donc des éléments précis
et concrets de votre part et je vais
vous laisser la parole dans un instant
pour que vous nous présentiez l'état de
vos travaux je donnerai ensuite la
parole à Madame Laurence Cohen notre
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
qui vous posera une série de questions
je précise que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je dois vous rappeler qu'un
faux témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible de peine prévue
aux articles
434-13 434 et 434 du code pénal je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant je le jure
madame Pauline londex
Monsieur Jérôme Martin
vous avez donc la parole pour un propos
liminaire assez court de façon à ce que
peut nous puissions rapidement arriver
aux échanges et aux questions je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup à vous madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur
messieurs et mesdames les sénatrices et
les sénateurs donc nous vous remercions
de nous auditionner aujourd'hui nous
avons appelé nos vœux la mise en place
d'une commission d'enquête sur les
pénuries de médicaments dès novembre
dernier donc nous sommes ravis que le
Sénat se soit emparé de cette enquête
c'est donc nous vous en remercions
très rapidement donc je vais essayer de
d'être la plus concise possible pour
laisser la place aux questions donc nos
parcours nous ont amenés en particulier
en ce qui me concerne à travailler
beaucoup dans les pays à bail moyen
revenus qui sont confrontés depuis très
longtemps mais en particulier les 20
dernières années à des enjeux majeurs
autour de la disponibilité des produits
pharmaceutiques et de ses travaux aux
côtés de la société civile et des
gouvernements de ces pays on a pu tirer
un certain nombre d'enseignements sur
les stratégies qui peuvent être mises en
place pour permettre un accès aux
médicaments et améliorer la production
et limiter les pénuries
peut-être un élément clé qui nous paraît
important ici précisé c'est que on a
assisté à un tournant en 2014 en France
avec la mise sur le marché d'un
médicament contre l'hépatite virale
c'est le Sophos buvière pour 56000 euros
par traitement par personne ce qui et
qui valait on avait fait le calcul pour
médecin du monde pour qui j'étais
consultante à l'époque à deux fois le
budget des hôpitaux de Paris de la PHP
pour un an si tout le monde en France en
avait bénéficié toutes les personnes en
ayant le besoin à ce moment-là donc ça
montrait clairement qu'il y allait avoir
un problème d'accès aux médicaments en
France à court ou moyen terme
donc je voudrais rappeler aussi pourquoi
on mène ce combat on met ce combat parce
que des gens n'ont pas accès à à des
médicaments que des pertes de chances
liées aux pénuries de médicaments
compromettent la vie de certaines
personnes y compris en France ça fait
partie des témoignages qu'on a fait
qu'on a vu remonter des différents des
différentes des différents endroits en
France depuis 6 mois et ça nous inquiète
profondément on a vu des gens mourir à
cause de ça en général depuis le début
de notre lutte sur cette question et
c'est pour ça que nous menons ce combat
donc on a vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente on a constaté les
conséquences dramatiques de l'opacité
sur la chaîne du médicament qui empêche
selon nous la prise de de position de
décision éclairée de la part des élus et
également aussi une analyse de la part
par exemple des journalistes qui n'ont
pas forcément accès aux données donc il
y a un problème d'accès à des données
qui permettent ensuite une analyse pour
guider les politiques publiques et c'est
ce qui a poussé nous a poussé en juin
2019 a créé l'Observatoire de la
transparence dans les politiques du
médicament donc nous travaillons nous
aimons dire que nous travaillons au
croisement de différentes expertises
comme la pharmacologie la pharmacologie
industrielle l'économie de la santé et
le droit de la propriété intellectuelle
et l'épidémiologie et c'est la mise en
commun de ces différentes expertises qui
permettent de comprendre d'analyser de
voir où est-ce qu'on peut aller
les pénuries de médicaments alors je
vais citer très rapidement un article
paru le 22 mars 2023 des médicaments
distribués au compte-goutte pour limiter
la pénurie pharmacie devrait les
pharmacies devraient limiter certains
médicaments en quantité donc plus limité
devrait délivrer en quantité quitte à
fractionner les emballages cette
recommandation s'applique des Jeudis
c'est une mesure prise pour prévenir les
pour faire face aux pénurie de
médicaments dans ce contexte allons vers
une hausse de prix en effet des baisses
de prix peuvent amener les fabricants à
retirer certains produits du marché en
raison du manque de rentabilité fin de
citation est-ce qu'on parle de la France
non il s'agit d'un article de la RTS
donc un article Suisse
en moyenne les prix des produits
originaux tombés dans le domaine public
serait environ 10% plus bas dans les
pays de dans les pays européens en
comparaison de la Suisse s'agissante
générique l'écart de prix de 42% ils
sont 42% plus cher en Suisse donc on a
entendu depuis le début de vos éditions
les industriels mettre en avant la
question du prix comme une raison
expliquant les pénuries là dans le dans
l'exemple avec l'exemple Suisse on se
rend bien compte que même 42% plus cher
il y a quand même des pénuries en Suisse
donc combien à combien de pourcentages
doit-on relever le prix des médicaments
pour faire face aux pénuries
donc c'est pénuries sont structurelles
beaucoup des personnes que vous avez
auditionnées le rappeler elles sont
multifactorielles là aussi ce terme est
revenu régulièrement elles sont
également conjoncturelles on a passé en
revue le site de la NSM et on se rend
compte que sur le site de la NSM il est
très difficile de trouver des
informations précises sur les pénuries
c'est à dire les tensions les
contingentements on a beaucoup de mal à
très peu de lisibilité sur les dates de
remise sur le marché les remises édition
on se rend compte qu'il y a aussi un
flou sémantique autour du mot tension
parce que on pourrait imaginer de façon
intuitive que le mot tension signifie
que il n'y a pas de rupture dans la
réalité on se rend compte que beaucoup
de tensions conduisent à des
contingentements donc il faut faire
attention avec ce terme de tension
si on a également analysé les les
médicaments actuellement en tension et
en rupture 14 classes thérapeutiques sur
14 sont concernés et pour vraiment les
ruptures les ruptures donc là je parlais
des tensions pour les ruptures c'est de
13 sur 14
pour comprendre vraiment le contexte il
faut parler et revenir sur les étapes de
production de la chaîne formation
il y a les petites molécules il y a les
médicaments
issus de la chimie de synthèse il y a
les biomédicaments il y a les vaccins il
y a les diagnostics donc tout ça c'est
c'est des éléments un petit peu dit
enfin c'est des c'est des types de
produits pharmaceutiques différents
pour les petites molécules
issues de la biochimie il y a une étape
qui est absolument essentielle qui est
la production de vrac pharmaceutiques
donc c'est une phase d'extraction de
plantes de produits génétiques et
d'ingénierie ensuite il y a une phase de
fermentation d'extraction et de
transformation du vrac avec une seconde
étape de flaconnage de mise en
conditionnement donc c'est plusieurs
étapes qui sont qui sont différentes et
qui sont à distinguer par exemple pour
un seul façonnier il peut y avoir pour
lui façonner il peut y avoir un seul
produit producteur de vrac
pharmaceutiques donc si on ne prend pas
en considération la question de la
production du vrac pharmaceutique et
bien même même si on a huit producteurs
ayant une autorisation mission de marché
en France pour ce médicament ça veut pas
forcément dire que on a une garantie de
sécurité d'approvisionnement dans ce
médicament
donc nous notre inquiétude vous la
connaissez elle est que ce marché est
ultra concentré ensuite notre seconde
inquiétude et qui est une des raisons
pour pour ces pénuries ces
populationsnel on a une augmentation de
la population mondiale les briques donc
les principaux pays émergents
comptent pour 41% de la population
mondiale et trois
3,3 milliards d'habitants donc c'est
absolument énorme évidemment c'est des
pays où la capacité à payer pour pour
des médicaments étant constante
augmentation donc forcément si un pays
comme la Chine décide que sa population
doit avoir accès à telle molécule et
bien ça va rester sur le marché chinois
on en a eu une un exemple 22 décembre
2022 quand la Chine a décidé de
d'interdire les exportations de
d'ibuprofène notamment au moment du
rebond du du covid
donc on a ça on a également un
vieillissement de la population la
question de l'augmentation de la
capacité à payer des BRICS ça personne
ne le découvre aujourd'hui la question
de l'augmentation de la population
mondiale non plus la question du
vieillissement de la population non plus
on sait par exemple que les besoins en
paracétamol vont augmenter continuer
d'augmenter donc on trouve vraiment très
bien que on réfléchisse à produire du
paracétamol en France pour faire pour
pour garantir une production mais par
contre on sait également que pour
pouvoir couvrir les besoins les besoins
de notre population il va falloir des
besoins des volumes supplémentaires
constamment plus importants que ce qui
existait déjà
donc après il y a un autre une autre
question qui nous parait centrale et qui
a été très peu très peu évoquée c'est la
question du conflit géopolitique à la
fois on a peur on peut le dire ainsi on
nous avons peur que la question de
l'exportation des produits
pharmaceutiques puissent être utilisés
comme comme quelque chose dans des
enjeux dans des enjeux de autour de la
guerre etc les conflits c'est à dire que
la Chine puisse tout d'un coup refuser
d'exporter à certains pays pour des
raisons pour les raisons de conflits et
de et pour des raisons conflits mondiaux
et par ailleurs la guerre en Ukraine a
conduit à une hausse du prix de
l'énergie qui a des conséquences sur les
producteurs y compris les producteurs de
vrac pharmaceutiques par exemple la
production d'antibiotiques ou de
d'insuline et très consommatrice enfin a
besoin d'énormément d'énergie donc
forcément pour continuer à produire la
même quantité il faut plus il faut de
l'énergie donc ça coûte plus cher donc
toutes ces toutes ces raisons nous
inquiète particulièrement le dernier
point que je voudrais ici évoquer sur
autour des pénuries c'est les situations
il n'y a qu'un seul producteur on entend
beaucoup qui est assez qu'un seul
produit producteur parce que ce serait
plus forcément très intéressant pour de
nombreux producteurs de produits une
molécule en question mais souvent on se
rend compte que une signa qu'un seul
producteur c'est parce qu'il y a un
brevet c'est parce qu'il y a des brevets
sur le produit en question je vais
prendre deux exemples un exemple c'est
la rifapentine qui dans une combinaison
a été brevetée par par le laboratoire
par la firme Sanofi et en 2018 il y a eu
une impureté détectée dans une usine de
Sanofi la seule qui produisait au monde
ce traitement sous ce traitement là et
bien il y a eu une rupture et des
problèmes d'approvisionnement au niveau
mondial donc ça pose des problèmes
ensuite deuxième exemple le miso prostol
qui est produit par la firme norgine qui
est
qui est donc une pilule abortive qui est
utilisée qui est de dernière génération
et bien il y a eu également des
problèmes dans sa production en
septembre ce qui a conduit à la
destruction de l'eau et là aussi il y a
une question de propriété intellectuelle
qui empêche d'autres producteurs de
venir sur le marché donc là aussi il y a
un souci et brevet est-ce que un brevet
est forcément synonyme d'innovation un
brevet il faut reprendre le la
définition d'un brevet c'est pas
automatiquement synonyme d'innovation
c'est à dire que il se faut que
l'invention soit nouvelle qu'elle soit
qu'elle implique une activité inventive
et que donc c'est à dire qu'elle ne
découle pas de manière évidente de la
technique par rapport à une personne de
métier et qu'elle soit susceptible
d'application industrielle ça ça peut
paraître une évidence dans la réalité
quand on analyse de près les brevets qui
sont octroyés par l'Office européen des
brevets mais également par l'Office
indien de la propriété intellectuelle
l'Office égyptien de la population
intellectuelle on se rend compte il y a
des erreurs c'est à dire que parfois des
des brevets sont octroyées sur des
médicaments qui ne sont pas de réaliser
inventions dans en termes de de
propriété intellectuelle et au regard de
l'accord de l'OMC sur la propriété
intellectuelle donc on ne peut pas on
peut pas réduire systématiquement voilà
le l'innovation a au brevet
l'Europe dans tout ça
l'Europe dans tout ça on a souvent
entendu ici que qui pourrait être
intéressant qui est des achats groupés
européens sauf que si la l'essentiel de
la production de principes actifs et
concentrés en Asie et que et que les
briques ont une population de 3,3
milliards d'habitants le marché européen
pèse peu dans tout ça et je pense qu'il
faut vraiment avoir ça en tête donc les
achats groupés quand de toute façon la
matière première est concentrée dans
d'autres pays c'est problématique le 26
avril doit être publié le draft Pharma
législation proposes par la Commission
européenne on attend depuis trois mois
ce cette proposition malheureusement les
lobby font pression contre contre la
publication de ce texte qui apporte
quelques avancées notamment sur un
système de veille commun au niveau
européen sur les pénuries avec des idées
intéressantes notamment de lever de
l'exclusivité des données cliniques sur
certaines formes notamment pédiatriques
c'est intéressant mais on a noté dans ce
texte qui fait 1609 pages que il n'y
avait rien sur la production ni sur les
prix donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment
que les États membres et donc ici
évidemment en l'occurrence la France
réfléchissent à une stratégie en lien
avec les partenaires européens les
autres pays de production des différents
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs il y a des exemples très
intéressants très pertinents de
production publique et pas uniquement
public de médicaments par exemple
l'Egypte a réussi à faire accéder à sa
population plus de 10 millions de
personnes de médicaments contre
l'hépatite C en mettant une production
en place et le Brésil permet depuis plus
de 20 ans maintenant à sa population
d'avoir accès à des médicaments y
compris contre des maladies très rares
grâce à sa production publique je vous
remercie
très bien je vous remercie beaucoup je
passe la parole à Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
oui merci beaucoup pour cette
introduction parce que c'est pas facile
vous avez été une des seuls à vraiment
bien synthétisé et concentrer votre
propos donc donc merci moi j'ai quelques
questions peut-être à approfondir avec
vous
vous avez été vous êtes encore
des lanceurs d'alerte pour moi et donc
pendant la période de la crise de la de
la covid notamment
vous vous avez vous avez lancé un
certain nombre d'alerte auprès des
autorités que ce soit au niveau de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament ou que ce soit au niveau du
ministère vous l'avez fait aussi hors
covid je pense notamment à la
problématique des antibiotiques et
singulièrement de l'amoxicilline est-ce
que vous trouvez que ces différentes
instances que vous avez alerté ont été
suffisamment réactives ou est-ce qu'elle
elles ont elles ont trop tardé à réagir
et en fait effectivement dans dans votre
dans votre ouvrage combien coûte nos
vies vous avez pointé que notamment
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament avec quelque peu tarder à
réagir donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question tient dans
la dans la dans la transparence que vous
mettez effectivement au cœur de vos
propositions et ce à tout à tous les
niveaux on a vu quand même dans les
différentes auditions que nous avons
pratiquées depuis le début que ce soit
avec le LEM que ce soit avec le CEPS
qu'il règne et qu'il continue à rayer à
régner une opacité certaine c'est le
fameux secret des affaires qui bloque
pour avoir un certain nombre
d'informations extrêmement extrêmement
précise donc une des solutions
effectivement c'est de pouvoir
obtenir qu'il y ait une transparence et
du coup qu'il y ait une participation en
fait à tout à tous les niveaux de
négociation avec cette participation
elle puisse être ouvert à des acteurs et
des actrices comme des professions
médicales ou des
usagers est-ce que vous pouvez
développer cet aspect là est-ce que
comment est-ce que vous envisagez
éventuellement les choses c'était ma
deuxième deuxième question qui est assez
assez large et la troisième question
c'est que et vous l'avez souligné dans
votre propos introductif c'est que
effectivement on voit aujourd'hui que
les pénuries touchent énormément de de
produits au niveau avec des aires
thérapeutiques extrêmement différentes
et variées et bien
ces pénuries donc entraînent une perte
de chance pour un certain nombre de de
patients il y a des des traitements qui
peuvent être substitués mais c'est pas
toujours le cas donc est-ce que vous
pouvez là aussi nous donner des exemples
concernant cette ces pertes ces pertes
de chance enfin la quatrième quatrième
question c'est peut-être avoir un peu
des éléments encore plus précis vous
l'avez dit il y a des expériences qui
sont menées dans des pays comme l'Egypte
le Brésil concernant des
des
pôles des pôles publiques et en général
quand on quand on avance ces
propositions il peut y avoir un certain
nombre de
d'acteurs d'actrices de l'industrie
voire des politiques qui ont un petit
peu peur de la mammise de l'État et du
public sur sur les médicaments est-ce
que vous pouvez là encore donner les
expériences des
données un peu plus d'éléments sur ces
expériences puisque au Brésil il y a
effectivement
aussi des laboratoires qui sont privés
et qui travaillent et ça ne ça ne fait
pas d'ombrage ils ont des profits qui
leur permettent de s'en sortir mais en
même temps ça permet aussi de répondre à
un certain nombre de besoins de la
population voilà mes questions et je
vous remercie d'avance pour vos réponses
je vous laisse la parole Monsieur Martin
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur donc
je vous remercie à mon tour pour cette
audition pour donc reprendre les
premières qui pour répondre aux
premières questions de Madame la
rapporteur
les raisons de la politique et les
institutions ne sont pas en mesure
d'anticiper de prévoir et d'être réactif
je vais donner un exemple le 23 octobre
dernier sur BFM télé le ministre de la
santé et de la prévention affirme qu'il
y aura assez de paracétamol pour l'hiver
donc là je prends l'exemple du
paracétamol donc il y en aura assez pour
l'hiver
on était le 23 octobre le 20 novembre un
peu un mois plus tard au grand jeu RTL
il assure d'un retour à la normale dans
les semaines à venir le 5 janvier sur
France 2 il indique bon d'une part que
la hausse de 13% de consommation de
paracétamol n'a pas été anticipée
et par les industriels par les
industriels on a pas parlus par les
industriels et il promet un retour à la
normale très vite donc là c'est un
exemple parmi d'autres il s'agit pas
forcément de jeter la pierre sur une
personne sur un groupe politique je
pense qu'il faut raisonner en termes de
système nous n'avons pas les moyens vous
élus les administrations les ressources
politiques d'anticiper à la fois la
perspective de pénurie de tension de
crise mais aussi une fois que
l'électricité devenue des possibilités
de sortie pourquoi
comme Pauline l'a évoqué comme on l'a
entendu à plusieurs reprises on a été
frappé dans les auditions notamment des
industriels de leur capacité à dire
qu'il n'était pas capables d'anticiper
les causes structurelles des pénuries le
vieillissement de la population pourtant
ça s'anticipe et on connaît les besoins
et on est même capable de les chiffrer
l'exemple le plus frappant sur ça c'est
les pénuries les tensions d'amoxicilline
on se rappelle des causes qui ont été
bien décrites par l'Agence du Médicament
ici même mais aussi dans le
des médias une baisse de la production
qui est liée à une demande de
d'antibiotique beaucoup moins forte du
fait des mesures de confinement de
protection autour du covid à partir de
2020 et à partir du moment où ces
mesures de confinement salaire on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir fait beaucoup
d'études de médecine pour se rendre
compte que les agents infectieux vont
circuler à nouveau donc on va avoir
besoin d'antibiotiques donc pour nous
s'il y a cette déjà la capacité
d'anticipation elle n'est pas du point
de vue des industriels qui sont en
première ligne qui sont en première fois
parce que c'est eux qui font les alertes
ensuite là encore il s'agit pas de jeter
la pierre à qui que ce soit mais de voir
est-ce que le système est possible dans
un angle de santé publique ça paraît
totalement évident de se dire si on
enlève si on enlève les masques si on
retire les confinements si les gens
retournent dans des lieux de travail
plus d'agents infectieux vont circuler
donc il faut prévoir une augmentation de
nos lignes de production de l'angle de
santé publique ça paraît évident d'un
angle où on est beaucoup plus soumis à
des logiques marchandes de la loi de
l'offre et de demande surtout quand
elles sont tournées vers du court
thermisme et des logiques de flux tendus
ça devient on n'est pas dans les mêmes
logiques donc la question se balade
anticipation elle elle se pose ici comme
les déclarations viennent ensuite sont
faites pas les industriels ça arrive
toujours trop tard auprès de l'Agence du
médicament pour vous et l'Agence du
Médicament dispose de toute évidence pas
d'une capacité d'anticipation nous on a
une première réunion avec l'agence et
les associations de personnes concernées
par l'usagers antibiotiques autour des
tensions l'amoxicilline le 18 novembre
la conférence de presse d'annonce des
mesures notamment des mesures qui
concernaient les assiettes étaient le
lendemain donc là encore les
associations ne sont pas inclus et de
notre côté ben ça faisait des semaines
qu'on avait entendu parler par une
veille de média des pénuries des
tensions un peu partout dans le monde
donc aux États-Unis en Irlande dans des
pays où la boxicilline est beaucoup plus
cher au passage
et où donc on voit bien que ce problème
d'anticipation il se pose et il se pose
aussi une fois que les comment
que la crise a lieu comme l'indiqué
rapidement Pauline les
[Musique]
il y a plus de la moitié des
signalements de tension et de rupture
pour lequel alors que le normalement du
ciel doit le faire on n'a pas de date
annoncé de remise à la normale voilà
plus de la moitié ça peut se comprendre
par ailleurs vous avez l'exemple avec
renalou dans une des audition la
représente en de rénale ou sur le
belatta 7 qui vous indiquait que cela
faisait 5-6 ans que à chaque année
l'industriel disait au début de l'année
retourne la norme à la fin de l'année et
que ça s'aggravait
ensuite on a toujours sur les questions
d'anticipation
comment on a énormément dans la base de
données on a quand même
38% des produits qui sont pour lequel on
a une date de remise à la normale ou la
le comment le délai a été dépassé
parfois de plusieurs mois et dans
quelques cas de plus d'un an de plus que
deux ans donc voyez bien que ce soit au
niveau des industriels au niveau
politique au niveau des administrations
la capacité d'anticipation elle n'est
pas là donc oui il y a des lanceurs
d'alerte mais dans le cas de
l'amoxicilline par exemple pour tout
vous dire on voit que la pénurie est
mondiale qu'est-ce que nous allons faire
quand c'est un médicament qui est
utilisé à l'hôpital on a aucun risque
nous attirer l'alerte en disant
attention ce médicament là risque de
manquer on va pas ne risque pas de
provoquer de peur des faits et des faits
de consommation de masse dans un cas
comme lamoxicile
si nous on a l'alerte sans les moyens
d'informer les praticiens les
pharmaciens les Hospitaliers de mesures
pour faire attention on risque d'avoir
des articles qui vont créer un effet
panique et donc de renforcer le problème
donc c'est bien aux agences en tant que
tel de le faire et à ce propos à ce
titre là j'attire aussi votre attention
sur ce sujet là en matière de capacité
d'anticipation la conférence de presse a
eu lieu le 18 novembre les courriers aux
professionnels de santé ont été envoyés
cinq jours plus tard
par la DGS 4 à 5 jours plus tard
c'est-à-dire que le grand public était
informé d'une pénurie d'un médicament
symbolique qui cristallise des peurs et
des angoisses parce qu'il est beaucoup
utilisé pour les pour les enfants
il est relativement facile dans notre
pays vous avez beaucoup eu beaucoup
d'informations sur la question du
sur-rusage d'aller voir son médecin en
disant je pars en vacances est-ce que
vous pourriez pas c'est ce qui a pu se
passer et les médecins n'avaient pas
forcément les moyens des médecins des
pharmaciens pris par ça n'avait pas les
moyens d'entendre la communication grand
public donc voyez la capacité
d'anticipation là on a un exemple
concret de choses qui ne faut pas faire
sur la question de la transparence
est-ce que tu veux en parler les paires
de chance
sur la question des euh des paires de
chances enfin beaucoup d'associations
témoignent ici on ne va pas se
substituer à elle j'insiste sur
notamment là encore sur le témoignage de
renalou qui a permis de montrer à quel
point la question de la paire de chances
pour les pour les patients griffés
transplantés avait aussi un coût
économique il me semble que dans toutes
les auditions que vous avez eu on avait
vraiment et alors même que la CNAM ou
les agences les institutions vous ont
dit qu'il n'y avait pas d'évaluation
générale sur l'impact sanitaire le
commander contre le cancer vous en avez
fait d'autres on aimerait attirer votre
attention sur d'autres aspects peut-être
parallèle au père de chances il y a par
exemple des tensions de deux
antitrombotiques donc utiliser en cas
d'AVC actuellement pas des pénuries
sèches mais des antitrombotiques
donc c'est c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui permet ou bien de sauver des vies ou
bien d'éviter des comment des séquelles
extrêmement lourdes extrêmement graves
le
dans un contexte de pénurie de personnel
à l'hôpital
ces médicaments quand on les suites
régulièrement ça implique d'être formé à
des nouveaux modes d'administration des
nouveaux dosages donc ça multiplie les
risques d'erreurs et cette ça donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui fait peser un
long risque d'erreur médicale de retard
de retard de soins et de retard de prise
en charge voilà donc c'est un exemple
donc nous on a c'est remontées terrain
de de représentants hospitalier et qui
font bien le lien entre tout ça entre le
la question de du manque de personnel la
formation du personnel ces tensions
permanentes qui les obligent à changer
administrer qu'on a connu en plein
milieu du covid ça a été la même chose
aussi avec des avec des poches qui
arrivaient des dosages différents des
modes d'emploi écrit en anglais ou en
chinois etc donc on a ce système là qui
qui est imposé ce système D qui s'impose
et qui représente autant de pas de
chance n'oublions pas que les pénuries
alors l'impact des pénuries c'est aussi
comment des
du temps de travail en plus si on
voulait bien qui est
comptabilisable financièrement aussi il
faudrait dans les coups des pénuries à
pouvoir l'évaluer donc le temps de
travail des personnel c'est des immenses
en jeu de santé publique parmi les
pénuries on a très on n'entend très peu
parler de la question des pénuries de
réactifs et donc de dépistage ne par
exemple dépistage de maladies
sexuellement transmissibles qu'on a pu
constater notamment à l'automne 2020
mais que le contenu à voir et c'est donc
une réduction de la capacité à faire des
diagnostics donc des pertes de chances
de santé individuelle d'une prise en
charge précoce mais aussi la circulation
de personnes dans le de personnes
pouvant en contaminer d'autres sans le
savoir
complément
sur la transparence oui madame la
Présidente pour répondre à la question
de Madame la rapporteur sur les autres
modèles ou d'autres pays peut-être donc
depuis une depuis une vingtaine d'années
je pense que l'arrivée des traitements
contre contre le VIH SIDA en 1996 a
vraiment amorcé quelque chose dans
beaucoup de pays donc il y a beaucoup de
pays à bail moyen revenus qui à ce
moment-là ont commencé à produire soit
en confiant la production à des
industriels complètement privées soit
comme le Brésil en produisant eux-mêmes
publiquement donc il y a des pays comme
la Thaïlande
l'Egypte le Maroc l'Inde évidemment la
Chine le Pakistan de Bangladesh donc on
retrouve beaucoup des pays des pays à
revenus intermédiaire de la tranche
supérieure selon la classification de la
Banque mondiale dans ces exemples là
parmi ces exemples le modèle brésilien
est assez spécifique parce qu'il y a une
volonté du président Lula lors de son
premier mandat de développer une
production principalement publique avec
une articulation très intéressante
entre les producteurs euh les
producteurs brésiliens ferment guignosse
Bioman guinios et le bureau de la
propriété intellectuelle brésilien avec
également une bonne un travail avec
grande proximité avec Anne visa l'agence
de régulation sanitaire webienne et donc
ça ça a permis vraiment à la production
de médicaments contre des maladies très
graves qui n'auraient pas été
accessibles à la population brésilienne
et aujourd'hui le Brésil est un exemple
en matière d'accès à ces médicaments
dans les hôpitaux brésiliens dans les
hôpitaux publics c'est les médicaments
par exemple l'insuline et produite alors
c'est pas les formes d'insuline les plus
les plus forcément les plus innovantes
mais en tout cas elle est produite
publiquement et gratuite au Brésil pour
la plupart des personnes qui en ont
besoin ce qui est ce qui n'est pas rien
en Thaïlande en donc dans les autres
pays Thaïlande 1 de Égypte Maroc c'est
de la production privée mais avec encore
une fois une articulation très
intelligente avec avec le les
gouvernements une volonté politique
forte de faire accéder la population à
des à des médicaments vitaux et
également encore une encore une fois une
articulation avec les bureaux des
brevets donc c'est comme ça qu'on Égypte
le Bureau des brevets égyptiens a
constaté que même si le Sophos buvière
constituait une activité intensive
importante il découlait selon les
examinateurs du bureau égyptien de la
propriété intellectuelle il découlait de
façon évidente par rapport à l'état
l'état de
au niveau pharmacologique de ce qu'on
connaissait des connaissances et donc il
a décidé sur cette base de refuser le
brevet de la demande de brevet du
laboratoire Guyane et donc tout de suite
des des débuts 2014 de confier à farco
donc un producteur complètement privé
égyptien la production de ce médicament
et donc c'est ça qui a permis à l'Égypte
de faire bénéficier à sa population de
ce médicament et à quasiment éliminer
l'hépatite C de sa population que 10
millions de personnes 10 millions
d'Égyptiens étaient contaminés par le
virus de l'hépatite C donc tous ces
exemples montrent que c'est possible et
qu'il y a qu'il y a des exemples très
instructifs un dernier exemple européen
cette fois-ci touche concerne les les
bureaux les excusez-moi les hôpitaux les
hôpitaux hollandais qui ont décidé de
produire certains anticancéreux
notamment
anticancéropédiatriques qui qui
était destinés donc à une à une
population très très limitée en nombre
parce que le laboratoire Novartis avait
demandé un prix très élevé et que
c'était ça paraissait trop important au
gouvernement donc c'est également
possible et d'autres exemples existent
montrent que c'est absolument possible
je vous remercie
sur la transparence sur la transparence
et je reviens aussi à votre propos
luminaire madame la Présidente sur la
contradiction éventuelle avec le secret
des affaires c'était là-dessus aussi que
vous nous interrogiez
comment pour prendre des décisions
rationnelles il faut avoir les
informations on le régulateur il s'agit
du droit à la santé qui est inscrit dans
les textes internationaux dans la
Constitution dans le bloc
constitutionnel donc il y a un moment si
on ne peut pas mener des politiques de
santé et des politiques de dépenses de
santé de façon rationnelle il faut
s'interroger sur ce qui bloque ce qui
bloque c'est en grande partie c'est
l'opacité donc vous avez cité la
check-list de la transparence dans
lequel on cite quelques des éléments qui
seraient important d'avoir parmi les
éléments qui ne semblent les plus
importants
et qui sont au cœur des discussions que
vous avez actuellement il y a la
question de la transparence sur les
financements publics et les aides
publics avec une avancée donc nous avons
réussi à obtenir par le biais de
parlementaire et d'une union des
parlementaires avec un consensus une
retranscription partielle de la
résolution de l'Assemblée mondiale de la
santé par un amendement alors qui a été
une première année retoquée par le
Conseil constitutionnel mais qui a
ensuite été adopté l'année suivante mais
qui aboutit à de très faibles résultats
en matière de transparence et vous avez
un échange avec le CEPS sur ces
questions là si je me souviens bien
puisque dans la formulation actuelle et
de l'amende et de l'amendement et de du
décret on ne peut pas tenir compte par
exemple des incitations fiscales et ça
pose un vrai souci c'est à dire que je
le secret des affaires on peut en
débattre puis on avait un débattre
théorique une théorique mais là en
pratique
les citoyens ont le droit de le savoir
comment leur argent est utilisé le
crédit un peu recherche pour le prendre
que l'exemple de Sanofi c'est quand même
depuis 13 ans 14 ans entre 130 et 150
millions d'euros par an c'est beaucoup
pour les finances publiques ce n'est pas
beaucoup à l'échelle de Sanofi mais
c'est beaucoup pour les finances
publiques hors depuis 13 14 ans c'est
suppression de poste de recherche au
sein de cette multinationale
c'est une un abandon de recherche comme
Alzheimer comme les cancers comme les
coronavirus il y a 5-6 ans sur la base
de d'une étude réalisée par un cabinet
d'audit voilà qui a été recruté par
Sanofi cabinet d'audit qui a retravaillé
pour l'État pour le gouvernement au
moment de la gestion des pénuries ainsi
site web
donc on a quand même le droit ce secret
des affaires là on a le droit pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a le droit sur la question
du prix c'est déterminant y compris pour
le prix pour le prix des génériques par
rapport à ça on est prêt à vraiment
croire les industriels quand ils nous
disent que ce n'est pas rentable pour
eux que c'est le souci que c'est que
c'est un vrai souci mais dans ce cas là
il faut qu'il le montre or actuellement
ils ont il y a une disposition sur les
questions de coût de production qui leur
permet de le montrer l'article 28 de
l'accord-cadre il aura été demandé dans
l'eurodition pourquoi il utilisait si
peu je n'ai pas entendu de réponse
peut-être qu'elle aura qu'elle sera dans
le dans le questionnaire écrit mais ils
n'ont pas ils n'ont pas répondu en tout
cas c'est prévu mais c'est prévu montre
des éléments notamment sur les questions
de coût de production et donc le
monsieur l'amoureux le représentant du
lame disait nous avons toute confiance
vous ne croirez quand on le montrera il
n'y a aucun souci montrons-le pour tout
les produits savoir si le zogen Smart
cette thérapie innovante qui a été
découverte grâce à l'argent de l'Inserm
d'argent public grâce à l'argent du
Téléthon argent de Don défiscalisé donc
en grande partie publique aussi cette
qui est aujourd'hui vendue pour 2
millions d'euros pour sauver des vies de
bébé qui aboutit à ce qu'on faisait
tirages au sort en Belgique où il n'est
pas remboursé est-ce que vraiment 2
millions d'euros il y a les éléments
et seule la transparence peut nous le
dire donc coût de production être
montant à réaliser être public pour
savoir si un brevet est légitimement par
rappelant qu'un brevet c'est quand même
censé récompenser une prise de risque et
un investissement si la prise de risque
est l'investissement a été énormément
absorbé par le public où est la
légitimité du brevet et qu'est-ce qui
justifie que l'on paie deux fois les
médicaments et même d'autres fois
ensuite que justement les pénuries quand
on doit payer en plus pour les pénuries
donc il y a la réellement nous on est
tout à fait prêt à croire que le que le
coût de production peut parfois être un
problème responsable ou aggravant des
ruptures ou des tensions mais si
l'industrie est prête à le prouver et à
mon donner les éléments qu'on demande
dans certains cas pour augmenter faire
augmenter le prix elle doit être capable
de le donner pour que vous pour que le
régulateurs publics pour que l'Etat
puisse savoir si les prix sont légitimes
je sais pas si les collègues
je sais pas si vous les poser une
question
dans la dans la lignée de ce que ce que
vous venez de dire
sur cette nécessaire transparence et le
lien avec avec le brevet innovation
en travaillant un petit peu en écoutant
les auditions et en essayant de
d'approfondir une question mais m'est
apparu qui était pas évidente au départ
c'est en fait
la question de l'accès précoce est-ce
que l'accès précoce aux médicaments et
finalement un moyen de détourner ou de
ou de de favoriser l'opacité et que
finalement les autorités de santé elles
sont prises au piège parce que entre la
nécessité de répondre à un besoin de
santé et tous les enfin je veux dire qui
qu'elle soit quelle que soit la personne
à la décision quand on se rend compte
qu'il y a des bébés qui sont
menacés etc on est on se dit qu'on va
privilégier finalement l'accès aux
médicaments mais finalement en disant
oui à l'accès aux médicaments par ce
biais-là on dit OUI ou quelque part je
sais pas si c'est le terme qu'il faut
utiliser le scandale le scandale de
rémunération parce qu'on n'a pas le
temps finalement de de retracer toute
cette chaîne et de et de faire le poids
entre les financements publics qu'il y a
eu etc donc est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on remette ça en cause
puis la deuxième question qui est plus
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit un
petit peu antérieurement tout ce qui est
en train de se mettre en place là qu'on
est en train de travailler avec Pascal
grunis sur les réglementations autour de
la criticité des médicaments la liste de
médicaments
thérapeutiques indispensables et puis le
système d'alerte quand on vous écoute
quand je vous ai écouté j'ai eu
l'impression qu'on était complètement à
côté de la plaque est-ce que est-ce que
c'est le cas ou est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui va servir parce que dans ce
que vous avez dit je me suis dit mais
finalement à quoi ça sert quoi donc
Alexandre
Bruno Belin et Alexandra borchauffontain
merci de votre présentation alors nous
ce qui nous intéresse c'est l'avenir
question de mots quelle solution
et pardon ce que j'ai un autre engage
je préfère comme toi
non moi je suis toujours un peu un peu
choquée quand vous demandez à tout
savoir aller travailler dans
l'entreprise et puis aller voir
c'est un monde tellement concurrentiel
ce que vous demandez c'est quand vous
dites les coûts de production etc
forcément
on va donner aussi la main à la
concurrence donc vous vous êtes dans le
brevet complètement ouvert à donner à
tout le monde donner les coups de
production à tout le monde moi je suis
très choquée après quand vous dites
qu'il y a pas de contrôle etc tout le
monde fait ce qu'il veut sur sur le cire
le Crédit Impôt Recherche moi je peux
vous dire qu'il y a un nombre de
contrôle fiscaux énorme qui fait que
beaucoup en fait d'entreprises alors
certes peut-être pas les plus
importantes comme Sanofi mais des
petites et moyennes entreprises
renoncent parce que derrière il y a
souvent un contrôle fiscal alors je
voudrais pas vous laisser dire qu'il y a
aucun contrôle que tout le monde tout à
fait n'importe quoi et ensuite moi j'ai
une question sur vous n'avez pas parlé
sur les stocks
est-ce que justement pour éviter les
pénuries il faut pas faire des stocks
mais les stocks ça coûte cher qui va les
financer
merci
et donc Alexandra borchio borchio
Fontain non comme on est parfaitement
connecté avec mon collègue
vice-président et qu'il a parfaitement
résumé je m'associe à
ses propos et après
moi juste pour compléter la question des
de la liste des médicaments critiques je
pense que c'est un vrai sujet parce que
peut-être qu'il y a une partie des
mesures qu'on pourrait réserver
spécifiquement notamment sur le secret
l'estimation du cou du coup de
fabrication sur ces médicaments dit
critiques qui ont été considérés comme
étant essentiel au regard de la santé
publique donc de la part des
laboratoires
pour eux une responsabilité particulière
par rapport à cette liste là c'est pas
forcément faire un package global mais
au moins pour un pour un certain nombre
de médicaments est-ce que ça ça fait
partie des sujets que vous avez évoqués
et puis la question du coût des pénuries
est-ce que vous avez commencé à
travailler ou à une approche de réponse
sur ces sujets là parce que
effectivement je pense que la question
du coup des pénuries en matière de santé
publique c'est retard de traitement pas
de traitement ou alors bio similaire ou
biomimétique qui sont médicament de
remplacement qui sont pas aussi
efficaces ou moins bien supportés etc
annoncé tout ça est-ce que tout ça c'est
vous avez déjà des des pistes là-dessus
puisque ça fait partie quand même des
sujets quelque part qui permettraient
d'appuyer d'abonder dans l'arbitrage de
la santé publique et puis me dernière
question c'est en Europe vous avez
témoigné du fait que on avait le les
laboratoires étaient plutôt réduit au
rôle de façonnier et donc est-ce que
vous voyez des perspectives et quel
genre de perspective dans le
développement industriel pour que de
façonniers on place à un laboratoire en
produisant des médicaments
merci beaucoup
mesdames mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs pour pour cette
un seul monsieur le sénateur pour pour
cette pour
cette pour ces pour toutes ces questions
donc peut-être pour répondre et je suis
désolé d'avance si je réponds un petit
peu dans le désordre peut-être tout de
suite pour répondre sur les sur les
coûts de production sur la transparence
madame la sénatrice vous dites que vous
êtes choqué qu'on demande la
transparence dans un domaine qui est
ultra
concurrentiel vous avez raison
absolument mais la question qui se pose
pour les produits santé c'est est-ce que
c'est des médicaments comme les autres
est-ce que c'est est-ce que par excuser
est-ce que c'est des produits de
consommation comme les autres pour nous
la réponse est et non et que
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
conséquences du système actuel prive des
personnes d'un accès à des traitements
vitaux peut-être que si on peut nous on
comprend tout à fait les industriels qui
ont qui sont des logiques de rentabilité
et de maximisation des profits ça fait
partie de leur de leur modèle et on peut
tout à fait l'entendre c'est pour ça
qu'on considère que le public doit se
réapproprier une partie de la production
de ces médicaments si la production
d'antibiotiques ou de médicaments
intérêt thérapeutique majeur n'intéresse
pas plus financièrement certains
producteurs pas de problème on le
comprend mais c'est pour raison de plus
à notre avis pour le confier à à des
producteurs publics par ailleurs donc on
n'a pas accès à ces informations de
façon systématique mais depuis je tiens
à vous à souligner ici que depuis une
quinzaine d'années on a des études qui
sont publiées par des chercheurs des
pharmacologues qui travaillent avec
l'orgas sur mondiale de la santé avec
qui ont publié dans Le Lanset je pense
au pharmacologue Android sur les cours
réels de production les courriels de
production comme quelle est la
méthodologie d'Android Android a accès à
donc c'est un pharmacologue d'université
Liverpool il a accès à un logiciel qui
permettra au tracé
les transactions de matière première de
principes actif pharmaceutiques en temps
réel donc c'est pas des suppositions
c'est pas des choses abstraites il sait
qu'au kilo par exemple une transaction
de matière première d'ibuprofène entre
la Chine et le Royaume-Uni le mois
dernier a coûté temps ça ça lui permet
de en faisant un certain nombre de
calcul sur un modèle qui l'utilise
depuis longtemps d'avoir une idée du
coût de production et c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est rendu compte en 2014 que les
56.000 euros du prix du traitement
contre l'hépatite C donc c'était facturé
à l'Assurance Maladie ici coûter environ
100 euros à produire à l'époque donc le
différentiel entre les deux et quand
même assez important donc ça nous paraît
plutôt cohérent de pouvoir
pardon présente mais c'est pas comme ça
ça c'est pas décidé comme ça il y a des
tas de commissions quand l'autorisation
de mise sur le marché se fait voilà et
puis pardon une première réaction vos
propos il faut continuer de protéger nos
chercheurs et nos scientifiques si on
les emmerde trop ils vont continuer à se
barrer aux États-Unis ou à Dubaï voilà
c'est tout c'est le petit a c'est ça
alors peut-être du coup ça me permet de
répondre à votre question madame madame
la sénatrice sur sur le pouvoir de
négociation le problème c'est que le
pouvoir de négociation est extrêmement
déséquilibré pendant le processus si
vous avez comme c'était le cas en 2014
des centaines de milliers de personnes
en France qui attendent un traitement
contre l'hépatite C depuis longtemps et
qui voit la détériorer la détérioration
de leur foi d'année en année et bien
évidemment que ces associations de
patients et ses patients vont faire
pression pour que les négociations
soient accélérées et que l'État disent
ok pour ces 56000 euros même si c'est
pas forcément just peut-être très
rapidement pour finir et Jérôme va
compléter mais sur sur donc il y a la
question des stocks évidemment mais sur
la question de l'avenir il y a il y a
des solutions nous on pense que on
comprend que les industriels et d'autres
et d'autres éléments à prendre en
considération mais c'est pour ça qu'ils
nous paraît essentiel que le secteur
public s'approprie ces questions se
réapproprie ces questions pour qu'il n'y
ait plus de rupture de médicaments
essentiels et pour garantir un accès à
l'innovation je tiens quand même à
préciser que le Conseil consultatif
national d'éthique dans son avis de
novembre 2020 avait insisté sur le fait
que dans le contexte actuel dans le
cadre actuel le
l'État serait de moins en moins en
mesure de faire accéder à la population
française au prix qui sont en constante
augmentation ont pris des nouveaux
médicaments en consentement à la
population donc il y avait quand même
une alerte lancée par le CCNE à ce
moment-là en disant attention ces
augmentations de prix ne vont plus être
enables pour le système de santé donc
c'est vraiment une question qu'il faut à
laquelle il faut répondre cette
augmentation elle va de prix elle
continue si on ne met pas de critères
rationnels pendant les négociations de
prix et les pénuries sont structurelles
donc il faut réagir et nous ça nous
paraît possible quand on voit ce qu'on
fait les pays à à moyen un moyen revenu
si les pays a moyen revenus ils sont
parvenus et bien je pense que on a les
moyens d'y parvenir également
pour compléter répondre aux autres
questions sur la question des de l'accès
précoce on vient de la lutte contre le
sida et donc dans les années 90 a été
quand même un enjeu majeur pour les
malades et leur association
le combat qui a été fait pour
l'accélération de la mise à disposition
des de ce qu'il y a pas d'escalier de
devenir les crithérapies et notamment
des anti-prothéas pour avoir les
combinaisons qui a permis d'obtenir les
athées qui sont devenus ensuite qui ont
évolué récemment
donc il y a une nécessité cette accès
précoce il répond à des nécessités
éthiques en matière de soins le l'envers
et les associations de construction ont
été très très conscientes et ont écrit
des tribus sur cette question l'envers
de ça c'est effectivement une
possibilité de que cette colère soit
instrumentalisée par l'industrie pour
jouer dans les négociations et on en a
des exemples très très précis il y a en
2019 le laboratoire vertex a annoncé
suspendre des essais sur son traitement
révolutionnaire contre la mucoviscidose
parce qu'il estimait que les pouvoirs de
la négoci relation avec les poids
publiques sur les prix ne se passait pas
comme vous le comme il voulait les voies
publiques vous les diviser le prix par 8
au sein du CEPS et donc on a dit et le
comment le représentant en France dit
bien dans un article du Figaro de
février 2019 18 on ne va pas faire des
essais dans un pays où on ne pourra pas
commercialiser et donc on voit bien
comment là ce jeu quelque chose et là la
solution par rapport à ça c'est que
c'est au pouvoir public qui à l'état de
se mettre du côté des malades aussi et
de trouver un moyen de rééquilibrer le
rapport de force par exemple pas de la
possibilité de production publique par
exemple à les outils que Pauline vient
de décrire un autre exemple beaucoup
plus récent qu'on a encore et j'espère
qu'il est dans toutes les têtes et qu'il
a choqué tout le monde parce que c'est
sur du choquant de demander à la
transparence sur les coûts de production
dans un milieu concurrentiel mais quand
on a le représentant de Sanofi qui
annonce qui livrera l'Europe et la
France plus tard en vaccin contre le
covid parce qu'il estime qu'il n'y a pas
assez d'argent public c'était en mai
2020 je ne sais pas si tout le monde se
rencontre j'espère que tout le monde est
choqué et que on arrive à se rendre
compte que parfois la relation
dire le ah mais qui est des règles que
ça soit réglementaire et que ce soit
légal la question c'est est-ce que le
système fonctionne et est-ce qu'il
répond aux besoins en santé est-ce que
c'est dépenses là quand on donne cet
argent là est-ce qu'il est bien utilisé
et je pense que cette question là on ne
peut y répondre que si on a la
transparence sur l'ensemble des éléments
qu'on indique dans notre dans notre
chèque sur la liste des médicaments dit
essentiels ou critiques
donc il existe déjà plusieurs listes un
sel de l'OMS la liste de la glycémie la
liste des comment alors ce n'est pas du
travail ce n'est pas du travail pour
rien il faut simplement voir quelles
sont les critères que vous mettez que
vous mettez en place c'est du la
capacité à la mettre à jour avec de
nouvelles informations avec mais le
croisement il me semble qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est très important
c'est le croisement entre des
médicaments qui sont absolument
essentiels les médicaments qui sont plus
souvent en pénurie dans dans les
dernières années mais aussi des
informations sur la vulnérabilité de la
chaîne de production et ça je n'ai pas
l'impression que ça apparaisse dans les
débats et dans les discussions et en
tout cas l'ensemble des éléments par
exemple
imaginons qu'on décide enfin que vous
définissiez deux antibiotiques comme
étant dans cette liste critique est-ce
qu'on sait si on peut les produire en
France est-ce qu'on sait si on a des
lignes de production qui seraient
facilement réorientables est-ce qu'on
sait si on peut facilement produire la
matière première d'où on peut la faire
vous voyez il y a des éléments dans le
détail cette liste n'aura d'intérêt que
si on a vraiment quelque chose de très
précis en matière de chaîne de
production et de vulnérabilité dans la
chaîne de production
et sur les stocks
la conclusion des stocks alors déjà elle
ne correspond pas la mesure ne
correspond pas ce qui a été demandé par
les Associates de patients on est on est
retombé à deux mois elle est quand même
enfin la durée de 4 mois on a bien vu
avec certaines formes de l'amoxicilline
que ce n'était pas possible parce que
les pénuries précédentes avaient pas
lieu dans les deux ans donc là aussi
c'est un petit peu compliqué et ensuite
alors moi je suis prêt à ce que ça soit
assumer par les pouvoirs publics les
frais supplémentaires liées au stock
mais là encore il faut aussi que les
industriels nous montrent qu'ils sont en
incapacité de payer donc enfin voilà on
a quand même des informations sur la
santé financière de nos entreprises
concernées sur le les bénéfices sur la
façon dont ils sont réinvestis ou alors
utilisés pour les pour les dividendes on
est quand même depuis 3 ans depuis la
crise du covid a demandé des efforts à
tout le monde en matière financière
l'inflation elle touche évidemment les
producteurs ça peut être responsable de
choix d'arrêt de production quand les
médicaments n'est pas rentables mais il
se trouve que l'inflation elle touche
tout le monde y compris à qui on va
demander de payer maintenant les
médicaments parce qu'on n'aura plus la
capacité de les payer y compris ce enfin
voilà ceux qui vont devoir payer plus
d'impôts parce qu'il faudra payer les
stocks de Sanofi qui annoncent plus de 4
milliards de bénéfices de dividendes
pardon pour ses actionnaires depuis 3
ans donc il y a un moment il y a aussi
des choix à faire et il s'agit pas de
rentrer dans des il s'agit de se
demander est-ce que le système actuel
fonctionne est-ce que l'argent public
est bien utilisé je suis pour la
concession de stock si jamais il doit
être construit faisons-le par un circuit
public transparent où on sait que
l'objectif sera la santé et non pas les
logiques de frais de la demande laissant
les industriels privés répondre à nos
besoins quand ils le peuvent
ce qui me paraît intéressant que vous
avez mis en exergue c'est que
effectivement et nous on l'a vu quand on
est allé avec la présidente à Bruxelles
et puis au Pays-Bas on a vu que il y a
des règlements et que les règlements
européens etc en fait sont
de façon respectée j'allais dire c'est
un peu ce que ce que ce qui est souligné
par certaines et certaines de mes
collègues c'est à dire il y a des règles
etc sauf que moi ce que je trouve
intéressant d'interroger c'est qu'on est
arrivé à une situation mondiale où il y
a de plus en plus de pénuries
c'est-à-dire
en espèces de 10 ans elles ont été
multipliées par je ne sais plus combien
donc il y a plus en plus de pénuries
elle touche toutes toutes les molécules
sauf quand même les produits les plus
innovants parce que c'est souvent les
molécules matures qui sont touchés pour
pas dire le plus exclusivement et donc
il faut s'interroger et comme on est une
commission d'enquête c'est-à-dire pas
seulement les constats que nous faisons
et que nous pouvons partager mais
comment est-ce que on peut faire des
propositions qui vont permettre de
sortir de cette espèce de de cercle
vicieux et de permettre à toutes les
populations d'accéder au traitement
parce que enfin on voit bien dans les
depuis qu'on a commencé les auditions on
voit bien que les règles telles qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui
elles elles ne résout pas
les conjugaisons les pénuries les
tensions etc donc il faut on est là on
est aussi des législateurs on est là
aussi pour dire s'il y a besoin de
modifier les règles et bien faisons-le
et je ne sais plus je crois qu'au début
de votre propos aussi vous avez dit que
le paquet pharmaceutique au niveau
européen était était sans arrêt reculé
nous pour le coup puisqu'on était au
moment où ça devait être publié là on a
entendu alors or audition officielle
mais ça nous a été dit qu'il y avait
lobine et que
pas chez tous les interlocuteurs je ne
dis pas bien sûr il y avait au grand
dames des parlementaires ah oui c'était
pas l'homme des parlementaires c'était
pas les parlementaires mais les
parlementaires parlementaires faut
toujours être prudent on n'a pas eu tous
les parlementaires tu parles morts
européen c'était pas possible mais on
nous a quand même signifié que c'était
dû à des pressions et ce qui nous a
beaucoup inquiété c'est que nous on a
pensé puisqu'on était là on s'est dit
bah il y a un retard bon en retard ça
peut être bon à moi ou etc mais on nous
a fait comprendre que le calendrier
parlementaire étant ce qu'il était ça
pouvait conduire à peu près un an un an
donc or c'est quand même un paquet
pharmaceutique qui est en préparation
depuis depuis un moment et donc comme il
devait être quand on était présente il
devait sortir normalement il était prêt
donc c'est inquiétant
présidente pour répondre à votre à votre
à ce point sur la sur la politique
européenne madame la rapporteur donc
c'est vraiment nous aussi les échos
qu'on a pu avoir des différentes
organisations avec qui on en contact à
Bruxelles et également des d'ailleurs de
la presse des médias qui confirment
qu'il y a une volonté peut-être pour
certains lobbys de jouer la montre je
pourrai arriver aux élections
européennes et empêcher que ce soit que
ce soit débattu d'ici les élections
européennes je te laisse
alors sur la question de solution on a
abordé la question la production
publique avec ces modèles là et c'est
enfin nous il nous semble que c'est une
une des voies possibles une production
au moins public parce que ça permet de
sortir comme l'a demandé le président de
la République le 12 mars 2020 dans sa
deuxième allocution 3e allocution autour
du covid ça permet de sortir le
médicament le dépistage les vaccins du
champ de l'offre et la demande et donc
des problématiques et là encore il
s'agit pas de porter un jugement moral
ou idéologique sur ça c'est qu'on se
rend compte que certaines logiques ne
peuvent pas fonctionner je leur donne un
autre exemple sur le champ de la
recherche
la branche santé de l'OCDE et les
industriels eux-mêmes reconnaissent à
quel point pour eux c'est compliqué de
s'intéresser à au développement de
nouveaux antibiotiques alors même que
les antibiorésistances sont définis
comme une des pires menaces pour
l'humanité selon le MS donc a vraiment
une des antibiotiques qui ne vont plus
fonctionner par en masse dans peu de
temps et pourtant ça pourrait être un
marché et pourtant les industriels sont
peu intéressés sauf quand il y a des
partenariats publics privés donc avec de
l'argent public qui peut corriger pour
quelle raison ça tient là encore c'est
que développer des antibiotiques dans le
cadre de résistance et développer des
produits qui va falloir utiliser donc
vendre avec parcimonie en faisant
attention et je le vous l'assure ce sont
bien les industriels eux-mêmes qui le
reconnaissent ainsi que l'OCDE donc on
voit là un dépendamment des familles
politiques des choix idéologiques on
voit bien que là il y a quelque chose
qui ne peut pas fonctionner on a besoin
de l'argent public et si on a besoin et
on a besoin de la puissance publique
donc mettons-le sur quelque chose qui
soit totalement public donc une
planification sanitaire des besoins une
gouvernance d'une production qui associe
responsable politique syndicat des
syndicats des entreprises médecins
chercheurs associations de patients
associations de consommateurs voilà on
doit avoir un regard on peut prendre
exemple sur les modalités de la
démocratie sanitaire telle que la lutte
contre le sida a pu la développer il est
par exemple assez malheureux que la
mission comment
intergouvernementale sur les pénuries
alors inclus les une association des
malades mais il y a trois industriels et
aucun médecin aucun chercheur dedans le
point de vue la santé publique n'est pas
du tout du tout représenté ici dans
cette mission le il faut que ça soit une
gouvernance qui soit exemple de conflit
d'intérêt et de et de liens d'intérêt et
qui puisse permettre de définir une
politique de production publique et
cette production de production publique
va pas forcément dire production
étatisée on peut trouver en fonction des
types de médicaments des formes
différentes productions à l'hôpital une
production par le biais d'associatif ça
peut passer aussi par des soutiens des
collectivités locales ou territoriales
donc on est dans un pays très centralisé
mais il y a quand même beaucoup de
beaucoup de formes très diverses il y a
leur des une expérience qui pourrait
être intéressante sur le plan
intellectuel mais ou peut-être difficile
quand sur la production publique
d'insuline open insuline aux États-Unis
alors je m'appelle la production
par les États une expérience d'essayer
de produire de l'insuline en open source
donc qui poserait certainement des
problèmes économiques sur les
territoires français mais on a voilà il
y a plein d'échelle possible et
différentes avec quand même comment je
la question de la réglementation au
niveau de la de la qualité
dans l'audition de l'Ajax il en était
question aussi hier il s'agit pas de
rogner sur les questions de la qualité
il s'agit de voir si elle est adaptée à
tout type de production notamment des
productions de petite échelle on va
peut-être avoir besoin de production
publique de petit échelle pour faire
baisser les prix de médicaments
innovants ou d'innovants très très cher
par exemple voilà donc il y a cet enjeu
là qui peut qui peut se faire
j'ai une question je sais pas si
peut-être une dernière question en
matière de gouvernance qu'elle regarde
vous portez sur la gouvernance des
politiques sanitaires et donc des facto
de des politiques de médicaments en
France
parce que je vais aller plus loin comme
ça ça va vous éviter de dire certaines
choses moi je vais les dire moi-même
mais le le la multiplicité des
interlocuteurs lui probablement en tout
cas si ce n'est partiellement peut-être
complètement à la transparence
pour répondre à votre question nous
notre notre inquiétude après trois ans
trois ans de pandémie de covid et puis
l'année qui a précédé ou on a pu
interagir avec avec certaines ma vie que
certains ministères certains cabinets
ministériels nous nous donne
l'impression qu'il n'y a pas évidemment
peut-être qu'on n'est pas au courant
qu'on est simplement pas informé etc
mais qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de de
réflexion stratégique sur la politique
industrielle voilà et que ça qu'on a
laissé vraiment les industriels vraiment
guider la politique en disant elles se
sont compétents c'est des questions trop
complexes la chaîne de production et
mondiale ça nous dépasse donc nous on a
l'impression on d'acteurs qui sont
dépassés
par un peu par les événements et qui
n'ont pas
conscience du fait qu'ils peuvent avoir
qui peut qui peut y avoir vraiment des
décisions publiques fortes prises au
moment des alertes sur autour de
l'amoxicilline fin novembre on a été
assez inquiet on a trouvé qu'il y avait
une forme de gestion qui frôlait la
maturisme parfois c'est à dire que nous
pour préciser ce que ce que j'ai
remarque dans disait tout à l'heure on
était au courant depuis trois mois de
certaines pénuries on n'avait pas voulu
bien sûr alerté là-dessus pour pas qu'il
y ait des faits de panique et la NSM a
vraiment traîné en longueur pour
préconiser aussi certaines solutions
d'urgence à la réunion à laquelle on
avait participé la personne de la NSM
nous avait dit oh on va peut-être
importer des médicaments des
antibiotiques de l'hémisphère sud sauf
que nous on a fait une recherche rapide
ensuite l'hémisphère sud les gros
marchés de l'hémisphère sud producteur
c'est Brésil l'Australie l'Afrique du
Sud et bien ils connaissaient tous des
pénuries d'amoxicilline au même moment
donc là on s'est dit comment nous alors
que c'est pas la veille n'est pas
uniquement notre seul travail comment
nous on arrive à retrouver à trouver ces
éléments et on a l'impression que les
agences sont un peu dépassés et ensuite
c'est l'information aux soignants la
seule donc mesure importante ce qui
était préconisée c'était d'agir sur les
prescriptions le l'information DGS
urgent envoyée par le directeur général
adjoint de la santé voilà tes 4 jours
après la communication de la NSM donc on
a vraiment l'impression de je sais pas
si à ma tourisme c'est le mot mais en
tout cas qu'il n'y a pas grand monde qui
qui coordonne tout ça quoi qu'il y a pas
vraiment de réflexion stratégique de
coordination
juste une petite question complémentaire
par rapport à la production publique on
a eu un audition hier la GEPS et moi
j'étais un petit peu sidéré du fait que
nous dise qu'ils ont abandonné depuis
la production parce que c'est trop
compliqué ça revient trop cher c'est il
faut nettoyer les appareils
régulièrement alors ils ont fait sur le
sur le cura ils ont permis au pays de
fabriquer parce que c'est en petite
quantité etc mais eux ne vont plus ça va
pas du tout dans le sens de ce que vous
dites
alors nous ça ne va pas dans le sens
c'est le problème principal qui a été
posé par la représentant de la Jef c'est
celui enfin un des problèmes balancé
celui de justement des problèmes
réglementaires le fait que le mode de
production qu'ils ont n'est pas adapté à
une hausse de la réglementation qualité
aux réglations qualité qui est important
de par ailleurs mais la question de se
poser c'est comment l'adapter à des
types de production différents et à des
types de productions publiques voilà et
je me suis rendu compte qu'on n'a pas on
n'avait pas répondu à la question des
coûts
des coûts des pénuries enfin la des
coups des pénuries parce que j'étais
concentré sur les questions du coup de
des coups des stocks qu'est-ce qu'il y a
ce qui va les faire donc on a comme
on ne mène pas d'études pour le moment
sur cette question là on a parié enfin
on estime par ailleurs que ce n'est pas
à nous de le faire c'est toujours enfin
nous on est à sortir la transparence des
politiques ce n'est pas pour faire le
travail des institutions dont c'est le
cas voilà on a bien pris hâte du fait
que la CNAM vous avez dit non on n'a pas
de d'étude d'impact de y compris
scientifique et aussi économique sur ça
mais c'est très important et je pense
que dans tous les exemples que vous avez
depuis le début de l'audition
incluencent ceux qu'on a pu vous donner
vous voyez bien l'ampleur des coûts et
pour moi ça me semble essentiel
notamment aussi pour répondre à
certaines comment certaines réticences
ou certaines craintes qui ont pu être
exprimées ici sur laquelle donc qui
est-ce qui va payer qui est-ce qui paie
pour les stocks qui est-ce qui paie pour
ceci mais regardons déjà ce que nous
payons sans savoir évaluons déjà cela on
est en a l'habitude dans le enfin voilà
le droit à la santé il est très
important s'il faut payer il faudra
payer mais on se rend bien compte ici
que la question d'une logique de
rationalité de voir très réellement
pourquoi on paie elle ne s'oppose pas
ici avec des enjeux de santé individuel
ou sont techniques au contraire c'est
parce qu'on fera la transparence qu'on
aura des éléments rationnels sur tout ça
y compris sur ce que ça coûte que l'on
pourra voir au mieux comment utiliser
l'argent pour faire en sorte que le
droit à la santé soit respecté dans ce
pays
je vous remercie beaucoup d'autant plus
que dans le PLFSS on envisage pas
forcément le coup des pénuries de
médicaments et que ça se rajouterait
probablement très largement à la somme
qui a été votée je pense que c'est très
important de le garder en tête pour les
prochains pour les prochains votes si ce
type d'études vont être mené par la CNAM
d'ici là ça pourrait être intéressant
aussi
et bien je vais je vous propose de chers
collègues Madame Monsieur de lever la
séance madame la rapporteur en vous
remerciant beaucoup de votre
contribution
on vous en va vous envoyer
un questionnaire et donc je vous
remercie d'apporter les réponses écrites
ainsi que d'aborder éventuellement les
sujets que vous souhaitez voir aborder
de façon complémentaire dans le cadre de
de nos travaux et je vous rappelle donc
nous ne retrouverons mardi prochain à 9h
en salle Monnerie pour une table ronde
d'organisation représentative des
médecins
parce qu'on n'a pas encore eu les
prescripteurs je vous remercie